we're gonna go see my cousin my cousin
Samantha lives here who's on the planet
who's on the twin it they could be
anywhere in Paris morning my knee a
little chilly but your Papa says that
today's gonna be a warm day top of
attendance oh yeah it was warmer I was
on the 24th or so we see in the low 60s
okay today's gonna be a chilly day for
me at least if I get really really cool
it's close I know so yeah right now
we're waiting for the uber to take us to
a cafe to go meet with play cousin
Samantha we're gonna have a little bit
of breakfast and then we're gonna go
shopping and then we're gonna do more
wedding stuff that's today the plan I'm
looking forward to the cake tasting we
do
[Music]
and what if festivals all have our
airplane today yeah no he's been pushed
to the max whatever I said we're going
to the Hot Cheetos factory there's a
respect better than Rico Cheetos is he
feeling sick you feeling sick
[Music]
it's pretty funny Isaac's completely out
of it I've never seen Isaac actually be
so tired before they're usually hopping
off wall jumping around but this trip
specifically has worn him down so much
it's all we've been to - hey totally not
[Music]
I'm so cool cold just move around move
around fast
[Applause]
[Music]
there's not one shot a famous shot give
me your hand give me your hand
we're failing at that one shot oh sorry
I can't do nothing rubber in here
I just might you know it's not energy
son freak style what comes in a box like
that
hey max big Jack's he's holding
[Music]
do you remember when you were little
like you know you saw me holding a
camera and shooting you know movie
everywhere we go yeah do you think it
was kind of embarrassing that if we were
doing that no no now you're doing it my
dad used to videotape everything like I
feel like he inadvertently started
vlogging back in the 80s and 90s and he
was just way ahead of his time
unfortunately we didn't have the
capacity for cheap editing software at
that time so he never got around to
editing the videos the way he wanted it
to but he told me well I'm doing right
now these videos is exactly what he had
envisioned for the home videos used to
shoot for us so critical a came full
circle
alright we're entering pickpocket
territories holding this camera we're
gonna be a very walking target right now
[Music]
what's the smell like to you it smells
good no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so far so good I got
everything still my English he's very
smart
I begun on the path you know we rolled
him onto the ground they know my purse
isn't behind me and then he pushed my
purse in front of me very small such
tourists we come to a mall may take
pictures of the mall if you know the
beautiful night it's true that is true
even some of our museums on your look
this nice because I look exploring his
childhood in the French store where we
went to Japan and we went to a toy store
we kept telling him or you kept telling
him about like oh c'mon and
Dragon Ball Z he didn't get it and then
coming back home from Japan that's when
you've really got into Pokemon and all
his friends like love Pokemon their
trading Pokemon cards now he wants to
find pokemon cards in Paris wrong
country babies no I don't really like
these because it's like what is your
house without it you'll always be like
staring at you like you're walking or
than they're looking at you what if a
lion though I could protect you
uh-uh I mean we care the eyes eyes that
could protect you friends already watch
the movie coralline then I think you
won't like it
allo Coraline in that creepy roar in
that creepier come on with the eyes
without the head which one's creepy your
business creepier
[Music]
I'd really like those shoes I want to
pair for myself
the island oh look at your stupid
looking inside a little bit so why are
you buying shoes rising when we were
leaving the house
I told Isaac grab your grace shoes which
are these meters yeah they're fancy
sneakers so his dad bought him these
shoes he uses them for school so they're
all feet up now and I told him you're
not taking those shoes what did he bring
these shoes and then it's funny because
I told him to bring a whole bunch of
things because I was already focusing on
packing him explodes so I'm like you
focus on the other stuff of your giving
you that responsibility if you bring
anything nope not a single thing that
use was a ring so that's why now we're
buying him shoes plus it's kind of cool
you get to take a little piece in France
home so just like with my jacket that I
have when we went to Milan I bought this
jacket and so every time I wear it it
always reminds me Milan
really attached to this jacket even
though I know he's gonna grow out of
these shoes he gets to have something
from Paris yeah I remember when I was in
fifth grade we went to Hong Kong and I
bought a pair of shoes in Hong Kong and
when I came I didn't realize how cool
these shoes were when I was in Hong Kong
but when I came back the second semester
of fifth grade everyone's like oh you
get those shoes at your silver in their
shiny and they're all like cool-looking
we don't have that kind of stuff here in
the States and I was like immediately I
went from like other just shoes to I
know I'm the cool kid don't worry about
it I just came back from Hong Kong
that's all
just like me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and get people a headache from watching
the British motion go
slow motion reverse angle hello
no yes honey I don't get why you did the
face cuz you get hit you get hit you're
facing black yeah
[Music]
okay this is a hakama them and the
difference with the cotton issue is that
there's an egg on top of it so basically
it's French bread fisherman's and clam
and cheese
[Music]
so now we're meeting with any notice to
plan up the wedding really make
decisions on the venue and start getting
the ball rolling so it is an exciting
meeting right now but we haven't had
lunch so we kind of ordered a little bit
to keep as right meaning so or kind of
being a little rude and then after we're
going to check out a rental place if you
chairs and stuff linen things like that
and then we're gonna keep moving forward
with more wedding kinda getting things
done alright so now we're done with our
lunch / meeting right now we're headed
towards I forgot if it's the rental
place or the forest I'm not sure right
now in the - oh rental place we're here
we are here is option let's explore our
options options the place where you take
your options
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're about to meet the florist now in
her workshop its flower our lips okay
with it
he's not just a motorcycle man oh please
I should've been outside racing you guys
I made
so come in unity Africa us alone
[Music]
mom's always taking photos of liars any
chance she gets she's a she had a garden
before and like she really big in a
garden of flowers like that night it
looks like we finally caught her
attention never gonna be cake tasting
with Baker and I'm worried were you
bullied too that you may get some cake
oh my gosh these vain anymore bad in my
forehead my baby sis are you know when
I'm happy when these veins pop out cuz
that's when I like smile is it weird
that I'm selling it she's here is your
tasting she thank you we can talk taste
first and then we can talk design how
does that sound does that work alright
so furniture not my thing
flowers and I find my thing either cake
you might just want to have a bite
because we haven't got quite a dose of
cake so it was just say I will not be
upset if you do not be okay okay
as I trying to finish in that way but it
fit it in better that way sorry I'm
ruining the aesthetics for the camera
that important part is tasting which the
camera won't get to do sorry guys once
that you might like young man do you
like chocolate
you don't like vanilla you don't
strawberries so so okay I think that
what we're gonna do is I'm gonna get you
a plate and I think you need a nice big
pieces that was analogous to you I think
that's going to be your favorite here we
have tinny she is our cake master and so
we're about to try it try these
wonderful flavors okay here we go
the digging stairs
[Music]
all right after a long day of wedding
planning we were finally back today was
a super super productive day we picked
our venue which is a huge thing
we picked the cake we talked about
design and what kind of flowers we want
and the whole look and stuff and what
else we did a lot photographer
videographers it's crazy because it's I
feel like because that's what I do for a
living it's also really weird for me to
hire so higher so I'm gonna do something
that I normally do for myself so that's
gonna be a trip and so every time I
think about the way to get kind of
nervous I don't know why I don't know
where it comes from I start like my
heart starts racing but how do you feel
now that it's getting more and more real
I feel better about it like um I might
get emotional again again when you get
emotional so yeah so earlier today we're
doing the cake tasting the cake tasting
was cool cuz it was just cake and we
were just eating it right and then um at
a certain point I looked down at the
half-eaten cake that was in front of us
and I just stared into the cage I don't
know how I've I just stared directly
into the cake at first I was more like
okay looks weird when you stare at for a
long time all the colors you know I kind
of stays doubt for a second nothing
nothing important really and then as I
was staying longer into it though I saw
the past five years slash but not
performing ah I saw you know how we met
you know the early phases of our
relationship to me meaning issac to all
the different you know apartments that
we lived in over the years and then
there are hard times so good times to
what we have now to how we've basically
transformed our lives together you do a
little bit yes so the type of you have
your back then when we first met are
completely different people to who we
are now it's a little beginning baby so
no gimme
he's not in the wedding we're supposed
to do this too during the wedding night
now save this for the valid sleep I know
okay I'm gonna stop talking I need that
I need material for my vows just to give
you guys an idea of what the Eiffel
Tower looks like from the bed ever from
their bedroom that were staying and so
this is our perspective and then I turn
this withers to know when we wake up
where we get it from the bed right it's
pretty cool it's gorgeous
all right we're finally I'm so happy I
finally get to see it in person after
all this wedding planning you like
walking in circles
every time you like Sully
[Music]